the first time I was working with an
engine was incredible the ability to get
in there and such a finely tuned precise
machine and system getting able to see
how it works and like something so
powerful but yet so simple like at the
end of the day it's like you mix some
gas and some air together in a spark and
you get power out of it and that's like
pretty incredible John grew up as a
gearhead in Atlanta and he understood
that the average consumer when light
goes off on their car saying that
something's wrong they don't actually
know what's wrong and they don't have an
easy way of finding out so John along
with his co-founders Fred Grimm and
Julian Knight decided to build a product
called fixed that helped consumers
really understand before they got into a
workshop what actually is wrong with
their cars the application will tell you
exactly what's wrong with your car the
repercussions if you keep driving with
that problem and exactly how much it
should be costing you once you head to
the automotive shop for a very very
young age I knew I wanted to be an
engineer I just loved taking things
apart figuring how they work my parents
toys joke that I should have been like a
quality assurance tester for for the
automotive companies because I would try
to break everything that I could find as
I like kind of got this reputation for
knowing about cars like friends would
call me when they have problems and so
I'd help walk them through hey what's
gonna happen if you keep driving like
what's gonna go on how severe is it
where's where should you take it how
much should it cost so answering those
questions for people I kind of got to
understand this problem that people have
then like the anxiety and worry that
people have when they they have a
problem with their car and so we started
going around talking to drivers and
trying to figure out hey what is this
sense of anxiety that you're feeling
like why do you feel that and how could
we make something that could answer
those and so that's where the idea for
fix really came from and it was a
lucrative idea the company did nearly 20
million in sales and subscriptions last
year I got into race cars because I've
always been an adrenaline junkie growing
up I wanted to be a fighter pilot but
then about age 12 I realized I have
terrible vision and so that kind of
killed that dream but yeah at once I got
my license I just kind of got addicted
like the thrill of acceleration and
deceleration and being able to change
direction really fast and so racing was
a healthy outlet for that so instead of
doing it on
Rodi can do it on a racetrack John's
love of cars was also fostered at
Georgia Tech he was a part of a wreck
racing team which builds a car from
scratch every year to compete against
other universities part of the club's
mission is to to go and take a budget of
the dollars of the year so in 2014 we
had 2014 dollars to go and build this
car building the car we learned a ton
about teamwork having to coordinate I
mean 30 40 people in this club to get
this car built was was a huge kind of
task and that's been mirrored a lot in
in what we've been building fixed is the
ability to get people on the same same
page determine those priorities and then
put people in the right place that are
really well suited for executing on
whatever topic they're working on it was
a really great skill to learn and then
take into building the company I think
there are a couple parallels between
building a car and building a company
both you have to be very strategic about
how you go about building that thing you
have limited resources you have limited
time and you have to really prioritize
what you're gonna work on so just like
when you're doing that and designing and
building a car you have to do that when
you're building a company
you